good afternoon folks vice president
harris and i just received a briefing
from our economic team
and we remain in a once in a century
public health crisis
that's led to the most unequal job and
economic crisis
in modern history and the crisis
is only deepening it's not getting
better it's deepening
yesterday we learned that 900 000 more
americans file for unemployment
900 000. they join millions of americans
who through
no fault of their own have lost the
dignity and respect that comes
with a job and a paycheck so many of
them never thought they'd ever be out of
work in the first place
and just like my dad did when he was
used to lie awake at night
when i was a kid staring at the ceiling
unable to sleep because he worried about
whether or not he's about to lose his
health care
or whether we were going to have the
money to pay the mortgage because of the
economic circumstances
and now a lot of these folks are facing
eviction
are waiting hours in their cars
literally hours in their cars waiting to
be able to feed their children as i
drive up to a food bank
it's united states of america and
they're waiting to feed their kids
folks who are able to still keep their
job many have
seen their paychecks reduced and they've
they're barely hanging on
and wondering what's next sometimes the
anxiety about what's going to happen
next is more consequential than what
actually happened
but this is happening today in america
and this cannot be who we are as a
country
these are not the values of our nation
we
can not will not let people go hungry
we cannot let people be evicted because
of nothing they did themselves
they cannot watch people lose their jobs
and we have to act
we have to act now it's not just to meet
the moral obligation to treat our fellow
americans with the dignity respect they
deserve
this is an economic imperative a growing
economic consensus that we must act
decisively and boldly
to grow the economy for all americans
not just for tomorrow but in the future
there's a growing course of top economic
top economists
that agree that at this moment a crisis
with this with the interest rates as low
as they are historic lows
it is smart fiscal investment
including deficit spending and they're
more urgent than ever
you know and that return on these
investments and jobs and
racial equity is going to prevent
long-term economic damage and benefits
that are going to far
surpass the cost if we don't act the
rest of the world is not standing still
in terms of the competitive advantage of
the competitive possibilities
relative to us that our debt situation
will be more stable or not less stable
according to these economists and that
such investments on our people is going
to strengthen our economic
competitiveness
as a nation and help us out compete our
comp on competitors
in the global economy because we're
going to grow the economy with these
investments
while the cobot 19 package that passed
in december was the first step
as i said at the time it's just a down
payment
we need more action and we need to move
fast
last week i laid out a two-step plan
of rescue and recovery to get through
the crisis
and to a better and stronger and more
secure america
the first step of our american rescue
plan is a plan to tackle the pandemic
and get direct
financial relief to americans who need
it the most
you know in just a few days it's just
just been a few days since outlined this
plan it's received bipartisan support
from a majority of american mayors and
governors
businesses and labor organizations have
together
welcomed it as an urgent action as
needed
even wall street firms have underscored
its importance
in fact an analysis by moody's estimates
that
if we pass our american rescue plan the
economy would create
7.5 million jobs just in this year alone
that would be on the way to the more
than 18 million i think is 18 million
600 thousand
jobs that they believe will be created
over the four year period with our build
back better
recovery plan and with our american
rescue plan our economy would return to
full employment a
full year faster than without the plan
even president
trump's president trump's now not some
liberal organization
president trump's top former
economic adviser kevin hassett said
quote
he absolutely is in favor of this rescue
plan
this almost doesn't have a partisan
piece to it
we're seeing the support because this
plan takes a step
that we so urgently need more than just
the step number steps
it funds big parts of the covet 19
national strategy that
i released yesterday we released
yesterday our national strategy puts on
us on a war footing to aggressively
speed up our covet 19 response
especially on vaccines and testing
and reopening our schools i found it
fascinating
yesterday the press asked the question
is uh
you know 100 million enough a week
before they're saying biden are you
crazy you can't do 100 million in a
100 days well we're going to god will he
not only do 100 million we're going to
do more than that
but this is we have to do this we have
to move
the american rescue plan also includes
economic relief for most americans who
are in need
we're gonna finish the job of getting a
total of two thousand dollars in direct
payments to folks
six hundred dollars which has already
passed is simply not enough
if you still have to choose between
paying your rent putting food on the
table
we'll extend unemployment insurance
benefits for millions of workers beyond
the deadline that's now set
it means that 16 million americans who
are currently relying on unemployment
benefits while they look for work
can count on these checks continuing to
be there in the middle of this crisis
the american rescue plan also addresses
the growing housing crisis in america
approximately 14 million americans 14
million
have fallen behind on rent and many
risk eviction if we fail to act
there will be a wave of evictions and
foreclosures in the coming months
as this pandemic rages on because
there's nothing we can do to change the
trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months
so look this would overwhelm emergency
shelters
increase covet 19 infections as people
have to have nowhere to go and are
socially
can socially distance the american
rescue plan asked congress to provide
rental assistance for millions of
hard-hit families and tenants
this will also be a bridged economic
recovery for countless mom-and-pop
landlords who can't afford not to have
the rent but they can't
wait so on inauguration day
i directed my administration to extend
nationwide
restrictions on evictions and
foreclosures
these crises are are straining the
budgets of states and cities and tribal
communities
but are forced to consider layoffs and
service reductions
among essential workers police officers
firefighters first responders
nurses were all at the risk of losing
their jobs
over the last year more than 600 000
educators have lost their jobs in cities
and towns
the american rescue plan will provide
emergency funding to keep these
essential workers on the job and
maintain essential services
look it will also help small businesses
that are
the engines of our economic growth when
you say small business most people think
the major corporate entities are the
ones that
hire everybody these small businesses
are the glues that hulk
and they're important but these small
businesses hold the community that
glued to hold these communities together
they are hurting badly and they account
for nearly half
of the entire u.s workforce
only half our rescue plan will provide
flexible grants
to help the hardest hit small businesses
survive the pandemic
and low-cost capital to help
entrepreneurs
of all backgrounds create and maintain
jobs
plus provide essential goods and
services that communities so desperately
depend on
look our recovery plan also calls for an
increase
in the minimum wage at 15 at least 15
an hour no one in america should work 40
hours a week
making below the poverty line
15 gets people above the poverty line
we have so many millions of people
working 40 hours a week working
and some with two jobs and they're still
below the poverty line
our plan includes access to affordable
child care that's going to enable
parents particularly women to get back
to work
millions are not working now because
they don't have that care
all told the american rescue plan would
lift 12 million americans out of poverty
and cut child poverty in half
that's five million children lifted out
of poverty
our plan would reduce poverty and the
black community by one-third
reduce poverty in the hispanic community
by almost 40 percent
i look forward to uh to working with
members of congress of both parties
to move quickly to get this american
rescue plan to the american people
and then we can move with equal urgency
and bipartisanship to
the second step of our economic plan to
build back better the recovery plan
it's a plan that's going to make
historic investments in infrastructure
manufacturing innovation
research and development and clean
energy and so much more that's going to
create millions more jobs
good paying jobs not minimum wage jobs
we'll always work with members of both
parties in the congress
there are steps that we can and must
take right now
for example on inauguration day i
directed my administration to pause
student loan repayments for interest for
amer
the the interest payments for americans
with federal student loans
until at least september
so they're not going to have to pay till
september they still pay the bill at the
stands now
but they will not accrue interest and
they don't have to pay
begin to pay until september and we may
have to look beyond that i might add
today i'm signing an executive order
that directs the whole of government
a whole government effort to help
millions of americans who are badly
hurting
requires all federal agencies to do what
they can do
to provide relief to families small
business and communities
and in the days ahead i expect agencies
to act
let me touch on two ways these actions
can help change americans lives
we need to tackle the growing hunger
crisis in america
one in seven households in america one
in seven
more than one in five black and latino
households in america
report they do not have enough food to
eat
that includes nearly 30 million adults
and as many as
12 million children and again they're in
a specific
in this situation through no fault of
their own
it's unconscionable the american rescue
plan provides additional emergency food
and nutrition assistance
for tens of millions of children and
families to address this crisis
but families literally can't wait
another day
as a result of the executive order i'm
going to shortly sign it
the department of agriculture will
consider taking immediate steps
to make it easier for the hardest it's
families to enroll and claim more
generous benefits
in the critical food and nutrition
assistance area
this can help tens of millions of
families especially those who can't
provide meals for their kids
who are learning remotely at home are
not receiving the regular
meal plans that they have at school for
breakfast or lunch
it's gonna also we also need to protect
the health and safety of the american
worker
right now approximately forty percent of
households in america have at least one
member
with a pre-existing condition just
imagine you're out of work
through no fault of your own you file
for unemployment while you're looking
for a job
you find one and you get an offer
but then you find out there's a high
risk of you're getting infected with
covet 19
because of your condition you and your
loved one
and you and your loved ones have have
ever
even greater risk of death than serious
illness because of the preexisting
conditions
so you turn it down right now if you did
that
you could be denied unemployment
insurance because you're offered a job
you didn't take it
it's wrong no one should have to choose
between their livelihoods and their own
health
or the health of their loved ones in the
middle of a deadly pandemic
because the uh the executive order i'm
about to sign
i expect the department of labor to
guarantee the right to refuse
unemployment employment
that will jeopardize your health and if
you do so you'll still be able to
qualify for the insurance that's a
judgment the labor department will make
look there's just two consequential ways
that
the action i'm taking today will help
people in need another
another way to help approximately 2
million veterans maintain their
financial footing
by pausing federal collections on
overpayments and debts
another makes sure that federal
contractors are receiving taxpayers
dollars
provide their workers with the pay and
benefits they deserve
these are places where federal tax
dollars are administered are being
made available to build things from
ships to staircases
and the we let out the federal
government lets the contract
and we're going to make sure that they
buy american and are
made in america and here's another right
now there are up to eight million people
that are eligible for direct payments
from the cares act
and a relief bill passed in december
they're entitled to those payments
but there's not an easy way for those
folks to assess access them
so we're making it a priority today to
fix that problem
and get the relief they're entitled to
look i'm going to close and summarize
this way
a lot of america is hurting the virus is
surging we're 400 000 dead expected to
reach well over 600 000 families are
going hungry
people are at risk of being evicted job
losses are mounting again
we need to act no matter how you look at
it we need to act
if if we act now our economy will be
stronger
in both the short and long run that's
what economists left right and center
are telling us
both liberal and conservative will be
better and stronger across the board
if we act now we'll be better able to
compete with the world
if we act now we're better able to meet
our moral obligations to one another
as americans i don't believe the people
of this country
just want to stand by and watch their
friends their neighbors co-workers
fellow americans go hungry lose their
homes and lose their sense of dignity
and hope and respect
i don't believe that especially in the
middle of a pandemic
that's so weakened and wrecked so much
havoc and caused so much pain on america
that's not who we are the bottom line is
this
we're in a national emergency we need to
act
like we're in a national emergency so
we've got to move
with everything we've got we've got to
do it together i don't believe
democrats or republicans are going
hungry
and losing jobs i believe americans are
going hungry and losing their jobs
we have the tools to fix it we have the
tools
to get through this we have the tools to
get this virus under control
and our economy back on track we have
the tools to help people
so let's use the tools all of them use
them now
so i'm going to sign this executive
order let me conclude again by saying
folks this is one of the cases where
business
labor wall street main street
liberal conservative economists know we
have to act now
not only to help people our need now but
to allow us to be in a competitive
position worldwide and
be the leader of the world economy in
the next year and two and three going
forward
so thank you i'm going to sign this
executive order
the first one is the economic relief
related to covert 19 pandemic
the second one is protection protecting
the
federal workforce
thank you very much mr president do you
support mitch mcconnell's timeline for a
february impeachment trial
i haven't heard the detail of it but i
do think that uh
having some time to get our
administration up and running we
i want to thank the uh the senate for
passing out our secretary of defense
looks like our secretary of treasury
looks like our secretary of state's in
place so the more time we have to get up
and running and meet these crises
the better